we are doing a buoyancy experiment today
if you drop a golf ball into some
dishwashing liquid it sinks very slowly
so why does it sink in the detergent
because the golf ball is more heavy than
the liquid that's in there damn a
container then the detergent uh what do
you mean heavier can you elaborate on
that at all
probably more dense good and if I put
this in this is salt water it's very
salty huh this is the salty of salt
water you can make okay it's saturated
solution what will it do I think it
would be [ __ ] okay
Oh excellent so the golf ball floats in
the salt water
and if you have a look like it just is
sticking out just a little bit so what
does that tell you about it it's just
slightly less dense right like it was a
lot less dense in satire yeah the
question is if we now take the detergent
and we pour it in on top of the golf
ball what do you think will happen
little golf ball stay where it is will
it go down will it go up gonna go down a
little bit yeah
what do you think that well no let's see
what's later maybe look I have no idea I
think it would go down that a little bit
do you think this is going to mix with
that yeah that's what I was thinking
about I wonder if it's gonna make sure
if it's gonna later itself but he
doesn't sort of sit on top here yeah I
think this would be standing up so you
can make your prediction by clicking on
one of the on-screen annotations or you
can click a link in the description but
make your prediction now what do you
think is gonna happen to this golf ball
already in three two one